وفي تفاصيل الزياره قالت المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض ان زياره واشنطن تاتي تلبيه
لدعوه من الرئيس جوبيد للتاكيد على
الالتزام بدعم اوكرانيا امنيا واقتصاديا
وانسانيا مهما استغرق ذلك من وقت وكشف
مسؤول رفيع في الاداره الى ملكيه ان
الرئيس يعلن عن حزمه مساعدات جديده
لاورانيه بقيمه مليارات دولار تتضمن
صواريخ باتريوت وقنابل دقيقه وقال المسؤول
الامريكي ان واشنطن لا تسعى للمنخراط في
حرب مباشره
وكل ما تفعله ودعم الشعب الاوكراني واضاف
المسؤول الامريكي ان روسيا لم تظهر حتى
الان اي نيه الانسحاب من اوكرانيا ولم
تظهر اي مؤشر منها لانهاء الحربي بشكل
منصف
ينضم الينا من بيكو لايف مراسل الجزيره
تامر الصومادي اهلا بك تامر تضعنا في اخر
تطورت
نعم عبد السلام بالفعل الرئيس
زينسكي توجه في هذه هي الاثنا الى
الولايات المتحده كما قلتم هذه اول سياره
منذ فبراير شباط الماضي يوم اندلاع شراره
الحرب الروسيه الاولى على اوكرانيا الرئيس
الاوكرانيا
زياره تحمل كثير من الدلالات المهمه لاسيه
مع انها تاتي في ظل اشتداد المعارك في
جنوب البلاد وشرقها وتحديدا في محيط مدينه
التي زارها الرئيس
هذه الزياره يريد زلينسكي كما يقال هنا في
اوكرانيا ان يقول بان القوات الاوكرانيه
تمسك يريد من خلالها ان يقول بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تمسك بازمام المبادره تمسك
بازمام الامور رغم القصف الروسي المكثف في
عديد المقاطعه الشرقيه والجنوبيه ورغم ما
تحدث عنه بالامس ايضا وخلال الساعات
الاخيره قبل ان يغادر
عن نقص في الامكانيات العسكريه هذه
الزياره ايضا تاتي بعد ساعات كما اااا جاء
امس على زياره ذا لينسكي لمنطقه باخموت
الخطوط المتقدمه في بخموت وهي المنطقه
الاكثر سخونه الاكثر اشتعالا في الشرق
الاوكرانيه وعموم البلاد ولقائه بالجنود
المرابطين على تلك الجبهه وحديثهم وحديثه
لهم عفوا بان بانه سيعمل على تلبيه همم
المطالب المتعلقه بالامدادات اللوجستيه
والعسكريه من اجل انجاح هذه المعركه وصد
القوات الروسيه التي تقصف المدينه بشكل
مستمر والمدن والمقاطعه الاخرى خلال
الساعه الاخيره ايضا ظهر زينسكي قبل ان
يغادر الى الولايات المتحده في خطاب مصور
الى الشعب وقال وتحدث عن الجوله التي قام
بها على الخطوط المتقدمه وقال بانه سيعمل
كل ما باستطاعتك كل قدرته من اجل همم
تزويد القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بالسلاح
والحتاد تحدث عن حاجه بلاده لانظمه
صاروخيه دقيقه وبالاضافه الى انظمه مدفعيه
وتحدث عن نقص كبير في
الذخيره قال بان القواته تحتاج مزيد من
الذخيره ويتحدث عن الحاجه الاوكرانيه حاجه
الجيش الاوكراني لمزيد من المدرعات
والمزيد من
الصواريخ الدقيقه وقال بانه سيعمل على
تلبيه هذه المطالب الملححه التي وصفها
بالملحه بالقوات الاوكرانيه من اجل همم
شتاء ساخن على الارجح وهو ما همم يعني
يجري في هذه الاثناء في العديد من اجابات
القتال في شرق البلاد وغربها اذا هو يعول
على هذه الزياره كثيره
ويعول على مزيد من المساعدات وتحديدا همم
الحديث عن اكثر من ملياريه دولار من
المساعدات التي
يعمل ان يتم التوقيع عليها ويتم اعتمادها
همم خلال الساعات المقبله وسوف يكون هنالك
خطاب كما يقال هنا او كما قيل هنا من قبل
السلطات الاوكرانيه لزنسكي في الكونغرس
الامريكي وسوف يلتقي بقياده الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري نعم